Samsung just announced their latest flagship
tablet, The Tab S6 and I’ve got to say that
this is probably the best tablet for replacing
a laptop, even better than the iPad Pro with
its impressive iPad OS update scheduled for
full release this fall.
We’ll talk about exactly why the Tab S6
is likely a better choice in just a bit, but
first, let me tell you why I’m excited for
it.
Just a few months ago Samsung released the
S5e, a budget tablet that I genuinely really
liked but told most people not to buy it in
my full review, but the S6 changes that suggestion.
I love how thin and lightweight the S5e is,
the loud quad speakers, and on top of that,
the gorgeous AM OLED 16:10 display which is
great for media consumption.
With that said, there were a few big downsides
that made it hard to recommend.
The first was the Snapdragon 670 CPU which
is mediocre for today's standard and really
worrisome if you want to keep it for a few
years.
Paired with the midrange CPU is a weak GPU
which made gaming a very poor experience and
lastly, there is no pen support which is a
dealbreaker for some people.
We’ll the new S6 fixed all of those things
giving us pen support like the previous Tab
S4 and a CPU that can handle everything you
throw at it.
They’ve made some physical changes like
removing the side-mounted fingerprint scanner
opting for an optical under-display scanner.
I have to say that this is a very interesting
choice given their flagship phones use ultrasonic
sensors.
We also have an updated keyboard and a new
pen that's included in the box and connects
magnetically on the back.
We also now have dual-cameras on the back,
one being a 5MP ultrawide lens.
Even with these additions, the tablet is only
20grams heavier than the S5e and only 5.7mm
thick, meaning this will still be a fantastic
device for long handheld use, but this video
isn't just about the hardware, but about how
the new Tab S6 is a better laptop replacement
than the iPad Pro.
Since Vadim recently did a video on how the
iPad Pro is a viable laptop replacement, I
think it would be best to just let him take
over and explain why.
The most important thing that could make the
Tab S6 a better laptop replacement than the
iPad Pro is a pretty amazing feature called
Samsung Dex.
It’s basically an operating system that’s
instantly accessible from an app.
What’s so special about it is that it gives
you full cursor support and you get a desktop
layout that’s very similar to Windows 10,
with a start menu and app shortcuts right
on the desktop.
You get incredible multitasking with rearrangeable
windows and apps minimize into the menu bar
as well.
Not only that, but you get traditional drag
and drop file storage support, just like we’re
used to on a Windows or Mac computer.
And for years, Android has been known for
having much better file transfer support,
compared to Apple who is really only getting
actually usable transfer support with the
upcoming iPadOS.
To put the cherry on top, the available keyboard
case actually comes with a trackpad!
Now we won’t be able to tell how well it
works until we get the Tab S6 in our office,
but the built-in trackpad makes it feel so
much more like an actual laptop, especially
while in Dex!
While Apple’s iPad does get mouse support,
it just mimics touch input instead of actually
registering clicks, so you can’t really
use it like you would on a desktop computer.
With the Tab S6, though, you can plug it into
an external monitor, connect a bluetooth mouse
and keyboard, and turn on Dex to have a legitimate
desktop computer experience.
And to make it even better, the Tab S6 comes
with the stylus in the box, unlike the Apple
Pencil, which you have to purchase separately
for $130.
The best part is that the 256GB of storage
model only costs $729, and it comes with 8GB
of RAM compared to the iPad Pros 4GB of RAM.
And if you buy the keyboard case before September
22, you can get it for half off.
That means that with the Tab S6, you can get
a complete setup with 256GB of storage, the
Snapdragon 855 processor, 8GB of RAM, the
stylus and the trackpad-packing keyboard case
for a total of $819.
The 11” iPad Pro with 256GB of storage,
the Apple Pencil and the Smart Keyboard Folio
will cost you $1107, so you’re saving almost
$300 by going with the Tab S6 instead.
But while the Tab S6 looks incredible on the
spec sheet, things may change when we get
our hands on it and actually compare the two
side by side.
For example, there are way more apps on the
iPad that work really great compared to some
Android apps that suffer from poor optimization
and resolution issues on Samsung’s tablets.
So if you want to see us compare the Tab S6
and the iPad Pro, make sure to click the circle
above to subscribe.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next one!